the Joe Rogan experience when I was like
a teenager and in tears the irony I was
going in for an operation that you're
supposed to going in the morning and
leave in the afternoon oh it's just a
quick thing and then it was literally
for a circumcision I was like you were
getting a circumcision yeah what were
you doing I just had sex with this girl
like I was a kid like seven like say
eighteen and uh and somehow it pulled
the skin of my dick back I couldn't get
it back to clean it and I couldn't get
the skin back right over so then I spent
like an entire night with like a roar
boner with no skin covering it so I went
to the doctor then he got it back over
and he said you should get a
circumcision so one-time operation just
going and you'll have to worry about
this [ __ ] happening again but it only
happened once right yeah but you were
furiously beating off though right no no
I pull the skin to clean it yeah yeah I
was cleaning the gun shot my neighbor no
it's clean it if there was [ __ ] under
there yeah so then I went in and they
gave me anesthesia and then when I woke
up there was like a hose down my throat
and people were frantic around me and it
was like nighttime is way past the time
I was supposed to come back come to and
uh the the anesthesia gave me pneumonia
ended up spending like two one and a
half to two weeks in the hospital and
the first few days was in intensive care
uh Wow there's anesthesia I did not like
wake up
holy [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]